هنا محطه قطارات لندن بريتش احدى اكبر
المحطات في العاصمه البريطانيه في يوم
يضرب فيه اكثر من 40,000 من العاملين في
مرفق السكك الحديديه اضراب تكرر عده مرات
في الاشهر الاخيره وشل شبكه القطارات
بنسبه ترى وحد بين 80% و 100% في بعض
الاحيان
وهذه ذات المحطه في يوم عادي لا اضراب فيه
والفرق واضح عشرات القطار والاف الركاب كل
ساعه حتى انه لم يسمح لنا بالتصوير على
الارصفه بسبب السحاق قطاع الصحه هو الاخر
احد اكثر القطاعات تاثرا بالاضطرابات اكثر
من 100,000 من اعضاء نقابه التمريض اضرب
في شهر ديسمبر الماضي لمده يومين وكذلك
فعل الاف من اعضاء نقابه المسافرين وهؤلاء
وهؤلاء يخططون للاضراب مجددا اكثر من مره
في الايام والاسابيع والاشهر القادمه وهنا
يبرز التساؤل لماذا الان ولماذا تجمعت كل
هذه المطالب من كل هذه القطاعات في وقت
واحد والاجابه نجدها هنا في معدل التضخم
وغلاء الاسعار التي بلغ اعلى مستوياته
خلال اكثر من 40 عاما تقول الارقام
الحكوميه الرسميه ان اسعار الطعام بدات
خلال 12 شهرا فقط بمعدل بلغ في المتوسط
اكثر من 16% فدعونا ناخذ بعض الامثله
الحليب مثلا زاد خلال 12 شهرا بمعدل 29%
هناك مثال اخر لدينا الخبز مثلا هذا الخبز
زاده بمعدل 38 في المئه ولدينا مثال اخير
المعكرونه زادت خلال اثنا عشر شهرا بمعدل
60% تقول الحكومه البريطانيه ان التضخم
وغلاء المعيشه ازمه عالميه ان زياده
الاجور ستطيل امد الازمه في بريطانيا
وتقول الحكومه ايضا انها مستعده فقط
لزياده الاجور في القدر الذي اوصت به
هيئاتهم مراجعه الاجور المستقله ترفضه
النقابات وتقول ان تلك الهيئات لم تراعي
في تقيماتها وتوصياتها سنوات وسنوات من
تجميد الاجور من قبل حكومات حزب المحافظين
الحاكم في هذه البلاد منذ عام 2010 الخلاف
مستمر اذا وما بدا كخريف الغضب كما يحلو
لكثير من المدربين ان يسموه متى ينذر في
مواجهات كبرى بين الحكومه والنقابات اسد
الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن